Brenda song and Macaulay Culkin are  dating it's been incredible eat see can  confirm the former child stars are an  item this comes after the couple was  spotted holding hands and enjoying  spooky rides at Knott's Scary Farm on  Friday a source at the theme park tells  UT they were cute and very affectionate  with one another as they seemed to be on  a double date with Seth Green and his  wife Claire grant quote they all looked  super comfortable together and like they  were having a great night out eats he  spoke with Brenda before entering the  park where she gushed over working with  her new beau on their movie change lands  we had the best time everyone was lovely  we just got to go to Thailand and hang  out with our best friends for five weeks  woody have to say to all the romance  speculation between you and McCully  right now I don't like to talk about  your personal life but you're not  tonight  [Music]  you  [Music]